this is a production of cornell
university
thanks steve i appreciate the
introduction i also appreciate
the invitation from dr rebecca nelson
for the opportunity uh
hate that it's virtually but uh but
nevertheless
excited to to be a part of the the
plant breeding and genetics seminar
series um
steve kind of highlighted so my work is
is clearly
on the applied side but we also do some
you know theoretical research and and
look at ways to improve genetic gain
in cereal crops
and so you saw that uh primarily
my focus on uh winter wheat and sorghum
and you're
wondering those crops generally don't
pair well together
why why would i work on two of the most
divergent cereals in the grass
family and
you know from the from the macro level
when you look at winter wheat it's a
allohexaploid from three different
wild progenitors and a large genome size
of 16 gigabase
and then you've got an estimated over
100 000 genes
to pick apart and then on sorghum which
is a close
a cereal crop close relative to maize
it's a diploid crop with a relatively
small genome at 730 megabases
and only 34 000 genes
but um you know there's obviously those
contrasts but
but when you look uh more closely um you
look at weed it behaves
primarily like a diploid because there's
limited
crossover recombination events across
the different progenitor genomes
you look at the genetic resources so so
recently there was a
a quality reference genome in wheat
developed and there's
there's been a reference genome that
steve's been a part of that that was
done over a decade ago now
and so there's there's quality genetic
resources available there's
plenty of uh plethora of mapping
populations and
and genetic diversity to exploit for
genetic gain
and uh and there's also similar focal
traits of interest especially when you
look at the traits that we'd like to
focus on in terms of yield components
for productivity
grain quality and also disease
resistance which is obviously very
important
for our region there's also similar end
uses
in terms of both food products and for
the animal feed industry
and from the standpoint of there's a lot
of opportunity in the public sector to
make improvement for these crops because
of
relatively speaking limited private
industry involvement
in the in research and development
before i get into uh i've got multiple
projects that i really want to highlight
um that
that are more pre-breeding germplasm
enhancement genetics studies that
that are that were initiated to
supplement the breeding program i wanted
to highlight the breeding program
of what we do and why we do it
um so we have uh you know of course a
a fully fledged wheat cultivar
development pro
program as well as a hybrid sorghum
program
here at clemson and you know within
wheat
which we work with pureline cultivars we
don't
right now work with hybrid wheat
there's really two pipelines the
standard pipeline which
looks familiar to a lot of breeders and
geneticists which
we look at early generation mass
selection
and then at the f5 stage the f4 lines
f45 lines are genotyped for
preliminary genomic selection to to
generate estimated
reading values as well as getting marker
information
on major effect genes that would include
photoperiod vernalization
disease resistance hessian fly
resistance
and plant height among others
those that make it to the next
generation
we start yield testing and then it
scales up as most programs do
for multi-environment multi-replication
testing
the dh or doubled haploid pipeline um
it's just different in the sense that
you know uh dealt with haploid is a
familiar concept across um several crops
but
um but for weed it's it's a
well-established uh
pipeline to where you utilize you make
an f1 cross in the greenhouse you plant
that f1
plant back in the greenhouse and you
cross fertilize with maize pollen
and it uh the the maize chromosomes
don't materialize and you
you end up with haploid um
haploid immature seeds that you can rest
do embryo rescue
generate doubled haploid from that
process and then we can
obviously go directly into yield testing
because that is a
fully inbred homozygous line on the
whole
excuse me hybrid sorghum side
we also have parallel pipeline because
we have to work across
fertility pools to where we're
developing female parents and male
parents
in tandem and the early generation
selection process is different we use a
pedigree method of selection
and the in the f2 through f4 stage
and then in the f5 stage because it's a
hybrid crop
we begin test crossing with multiple
elite testers across
both male and female lines in
development
we evaluate those test cross
hybrids in generally two environments
and
and one or two replications just because
of seed limitations at the early testing
stage
and then if female lines and we use a
male gametoside by the way to
to be able to allow us to produce hybrid
seed at the f5 stage for females because
they are
male fertile but then if they
have a high general combining ability
then we look at
moving forward with sterilizing that
line in development to create
a1 or our female cytoplasmic males to
real
sterile line counterpart or a b line
to um to release to the
commercial companies for specific
combining ability testing
and and so on and so forth
we also use all season or counter
nurseries across both crops that
celebrate
the cultivar crop improvement process
for winter wheat our general counter
nursery in the summer nursery is
aberdeen idaho we grow winter wheat here
in south carolina
and we utilize that to advance f1
crosses to
to generate f2 bulk seed to plant
that the f1s are grown in the summer and
we get the seed
back in time for fall planting in
november
and then we also can increase double
haploids to go straight to yield testing
on the other side sorghum of course
being a warm season grass we have a
tropical
winter nursery uh located generally it's
in puerto vallarta to mexico we
we've also used puerto rico as well
but uh we utilize it also for advancing
f1s
and we also use it to develop our test
cross hybrids because
our environment here in south carolina
with the humidity
and disease problems that we have is not
really a minimal
to hybrid seed production
this slide is probably a shocker to
everyone that south carolina is not
kansas
which kansas is a state that typically
leads acreage for both crops
you look at uh how much wheat is grown
in kansas and sorghum 2.7 million
hectares per wheat 1.3 million hectares
in general for sorghum uh south carolina
not quite that amount right so
um there's actually only about two
million hectares of farmland
total in south carolina so it's it's a
different
excuse me a different um you know
demographic there in terms of
agriculture and
and there's different priorities of
course that that come with that
but but agriculture is certainly
important here in our state and in our
region
and when you look at just the amount of
mouths to feed
here on the east coast and a demand for
more local and sustainable
food you can see that we do have
water we do have a
food market and that creates a clear
opportunity we just don't have the farm
area and soils
that say the midwest or great plains has
in terms of the importance of feed
this county-based
map shows where grain is a surplus in
blue
and where grain is a deficit in red
and you can clearly see that most of the
southeastern
states or eastern states in general are
really grain deficit
and and that's due to a lot of ana uh
poultry and swine production in this
region
and so from an animal feed standpoint
there's a lot of demand for
regional grain production
and so within that framework in context
i i set out on a journey to develop a
cereal grain breeding and genetics
program here at clemson
and thought a lot about how to structure
that
and and really and steve alluded to to
working with industry
is is really i wanted to let industry
kind of dictate the major challenges and
opportunities that
we as a as a public program need to
focus on
and then in turn we can develop research
aims to
um and individualize schemes to make
genetics
improvements within the traits that we
we want to improve
and then also in general increase the
productivity across our top
target population of environments
and you know from that as you probably
saw within the abstract that's just
in my mind there's no current
one-size-fits-all approach to crop
improvement you know we've got to take
unique uh strategies and concepts to
to tackle whatever problems that we face
and so
with within that as well um the program
is really striving to
identify useful genetics to plug into
our genetic base and and improve or
boost
our genetic diversity within the program
to to capitalize on
and then also we want to look at
developing new selection schemes
and strategies to improve the rate of
genetic gain
and that's just what this schematic
depicts
and so getting into the talk it's going
to be three different
parallel projects that that somewhat
complement each other
but they're all centered around
productivity
quality and value and how we improve
those three
the first is a dedicated screening of
fusarium resistance in cereals
and i put cereals there because we work
across both wheat
and sorghum for incorporating resistance
to this
fungal pathogen
the second is identifying grain
secondary metabolites that
have antimicrobial activity this was a
recent
work done by clemson graduate student
lindsey shields
and then third is a orei
a nifa orei project
that is centered around low input
organic
management practices to
look at you know what is the ideal
sorghum
idiot type or what are the focal traits
that we should be working on to improve
productivity
as well as quality and value
so going back to screening of fusarium
resistance
in both wheat and sorghum uh disease
resistance as i mentioned is a
is a very important you know
focal interest of our program because of
necessity we live in a very
high humidity environment especially in
the summertime as
if any of you have ventured down to
the southeastern u.s in in july or
august
um you can relate and and not that um
new york is is that much less humid
but um disease resistance clearly on the
east coast is important
from from the standpoint of it's a it's
a great
conducive environment for fungal
pathogen growth
and uh and within fusarium specifically
the dominant species within wheat is
fucerium gramaneerum
it generates the dominant toxin
deoxynovalenol or don
and the threshold of don in foods is one
part
per million in swine and feeding swine
is 5 ppm in sorghum the dominant species
even though it varies a lot as well as
wheat it is
verticillioides and the dominant toxin
is fumonosyn
uh fumonos in b1 and the food threshold
is still very low up four parts per
million
and so from a farmer's perspective
these traits for breeding resistance is
obviously critical right because
they either have two options if they
have an infestation of these
these mycotoxins they can sell it at a
very reduced price
or a more likely scenario
is they turn around and go back to their
farms and dump it on their land
somewhere
so how do we screen for fusarium
resistance in wheat
so steve mentioned in the introduction
that i'm a part of the us wheat and
barley scab initiative
within that initiative that was
established about 15 years ago there's a
coordinated project for variety
development and host resistance
and we collaborators within that project
all have a missed irrigated and
inoculated wheat scab nursery that
we evaluate every year a lot of
different
varieties and and improved lines that
are in the
cultivar development pipeline and how we
do that is we
isolate fuser and grim nerum spores from
the previous year's crop from infested
heads
we culture those isolates um
in a among being broth
and then take that broth and then
put that into autoclave maze kernels to
where
we develop develop this scabby maze
inoculum
as you see in that picture in the middle
and the bottom
as you can see the mycelial development
there after two or three weeks of
of culturing in that scabby maze we can
take we can break that up and we
actually
we deploy the individual maze kernels
and scatter them out by hand
to create as even as as a disease
pressure
a few serum numbers we can get across
the fields
for a relative field screening rating
and
a good measure of disease resistance for
this fungal pathogen
we're also developing uh
measures to more objectively evaluate
important traits associated with fusarum
head blight
or scab which is it's typically called
and one of the traits that we focus on
is called fdk which stands for fusarium
damaged kernels
which fusarium comes in and infects that
flowering
and then it and then it progresses into
the seed in early development and
prevents normal grain field duration so
our normal grain filling and so you end
up with shriveled
seeds that are typically blighted or
bleached in color
and so you can utilize both color and
seed
size dimensions to develop a proprietary
algorithm and this was done by the
company by the
imaging analytics that that sent us a
vibe green
analyzer to do this
and how does this work very quickly you
can see that there is
a mixture of different colored grains of
wheat kernels here
you have normal wheat color or wheat
kernels that are
have that typical soft red wheat
characteristics and then you have the
blighted seed
which are bleached and and lighter in
color and they're also tend to be
we call them tombstones because they're
a lot narrower because of the lack of
grain feel
and so this is a picture by the vibe
and in the user interface and this is
after
analysis you look at it it individually
analyzes each
kernel and it determines based on that
calibration of color and size dimensions
which seeds are classified as
fdk or fusarium damaged kernels and then
it gives an overall percentage
within that sample if you look in the
bottom right here is the overall
percentage of 34 percent
of this sample and so this is a very
important objective
measure for screening fhp resistance
that we're deploying
and it's very accurate i won't go into
the details of this
this slide because i want to focus more
downstream uh
of why we're utilizing this objectively
but
but you can see if you just look at
samples that were that were harvested
and sent from winsboro louisiana that
this new vibe instrument is
has shown to be much more effective
when compared to nr spectroscopy
the visual ratings which we sometimes
still use manual ratings which are our
pain because you have to literally count
out kernels
and it's still subjective and then the
gold standards is actually
measuring the content of the the levels
of deoxynovalenol are done
within the grain and so we were
comparing how
how well the vibe compared or correlated
with
with the oxygen of elenol and it turns
out it was is very highly correlated
more than the other methods
so so we take that severity or fdk
measure
and we're actually incorporating that
into um
developing training populations for
wheat
to screen for fhp resistance and that's
what this slide
shows on how accurate we're getting
in genomic prediction for this trait
and it turns out you look at a
correlation or prediction accuracy of
almost 0.7
it turns out that for um for several
reasons that you can
you can predict based on genomics
fusarium resistant
lines or susceptible lines very well
and if you look at the different uh
the different symbols and colors in this
graph
what it's getting at is you look at the
top 25 percent
of lines and the top 25 percent being
the most
resistance to fhb are outlined in red
and then the bottom 75 are highlighted
in blue
and then this the different shape of the
symbol
denotes whether it was in the top 25
percent for ftk
or fdk and on or just don
or it wasn't predicted in the top
quarter
by either of those traits or in
combination
and so you can see that there's this
cluster of lines here
that have this that do not have this the
cross
are or plus signs that denote that most
of these
that we would select based on
observations which is the y-axis
were also predicted in the top 25
percent which is in that lower right
quadrant
if you look at fdk alone which is the
same trade as severity
you you can see in circles here um
one two three four five six seven seven
of the eight
were predicted in that bottom
left quadrant which is what you would
ideally select on
so we're implementing genomic prediction
for this trait and it's working very
well and just in context so every year
within the sun grains program that that
clemson is a part of
uh we evaluate between three to four
thousand wheat lines that get
genotyping by sequencing data each year
we're also utilizing genomic prediction
to
to try to predict population variance
and tell us which
crosses we should make or what parents
we should use and
what combinations we sh we should make
from those parents
and this was a a result of a program
called pop bar which is an r package
program developed by
mohsin mohammadi at the university or
purdue university
and what it what it generates is based
on a combination in the genetics
or genomics sequence of each parent
it generates estimating breeding values
of
all of the cross progenies from that
cross
so all of the progeny from the cross
so it generates different parameters
including the mean but but more
importantly the population
variance we want the population variance
to be
be large to enable more more selection
and then also we want uh
the we want transgressive segregates to
be able to select
lines that are more resistant than both
of their parents combined
and taking advantage of additive genetic
variation
and so it generates the program
generates the mean lowest 10 percent and
again this is for
fhb resistance so we want the lowest
um 10 percent
in this if it for yield it would be the
highest 10 percent
and so we utilize that program and it's
working very well
um we're also cross-cutting research
into sorghum
and this is a project that my graduate
student aj ackerman is working on
and it's looking at different types of
resistance to fusion and verticillioides
but i'm just going to fly through these
a little bit so i can get through them
but
um but they published a review aj did
along with
with anthony wendt who was at cornell
and part of the nelson lab
and looked at potential pathways that
are important for disease mechanisms
disease resistance mechanisms in sorghum
specifically for fusarium grain mold
resistance
and aj looked he took a
very resistant genotype and a very
susceptible genotype and generated
untargeted
metabolomics on that and
this is what the volcano plot is showing
each dot represents
a mass feature a metabolite and those
that are
on the left side have a much higher
relative abundance
compared to the sys the abundance of the
susceptible
uh genotype and vice versa on the right
side and red
what i just wanted to quickly point out
is
he quickly found that those that had the
highest confidence
uh those metabolites are mass teachers
with the highest confidence and then the
greatest full
change they tended to show up in the
flavonoid
pathway and putatively speaking
and this just shows a kind of a
contorted pca
to visualize discriminating
variants or metabolites in this example
to
to also show that there were um
several metabolites that were within
this flavonoid pathway
way that specifically were part of
xenobiosis putative function
and so um wrapping up part one um
we we looked at incorporating that
objective fhb
phenotyping platform and its help
genomic prediction efforts
that's being has been implemented well
for this trait
we've looked at
through untargeted metabolomics we found
an enrichment of sorghum grain
flavonoids
after a few serum inoculation
and uh and more on on the the last
bullet there is like
using untargeted metabolomic data from
variable genotypes
it kind of offers a relatively unique
approach to infer mechanisms of
resistance
so i'll talk a little bit more about
that in this second part
so this was a project again done by
former graduate student lindsey shields
this was published recently in crop
science and it was looking at
antimicrobial activity in sorghum and
trying to predict
or identify the genetic components of
that
why do we want to look at antimicrobial
activity in sorghum well
one there's been a big push in the
poultry industry for
um antibiotic-free poultry production
but there's still plenty of food-borne
pathogens to deal with
and so if you can incorporate a natural
antibiotic component
or antimicrobial activity component in
the grain
which sorghum is a major feed component
it's a win-win
and and also i mentioned that south
carolina is a major
as a grain deficit state and import or
feed grain so
so we wanted to look at antimicrobial
activity and we looked at a lot of
different accessions from the sorghum
association panel grown in the field we
took that grain we ground it down
and we extracted secondary metabolites
from that ground grain
and then we looked at a
kind of a crude method of
measuring antimicrobial activity i'll
talk about that in the next slide
and then based on that quantitative
measure
we looked at genome-wide association
mapping
this is called a disk diffusion assay
and this was done in
dr chu ping jing's lab here at clemson a
microbiologist
we looked at two different pathos
pathogens salmonella enteric and
clostridium perfringens
and you can see that on the petri dish
is a lawn of bacteria
and we we placed a sterile cotton disc
that was saturated with the
with the sorghum extract of all these
different genotypes
and we measured the receding growth
from that cotton disc and how we
measured it we looked at the diameter
across the circle there
this was a tetracycline antibiotic
control and you look here is a sorghum
line
extract from a sorghum line that had a
9.4 millimeter inhibition
so we did see considerable antimicrobial
activity
what we were scared of was that all this
activity was
dependent on condensed tannins and
polyphenols that are typically
anti-nutritional from a feed standpoint
but when we looked at that relationship
we measured condensed tannins and total
polyphenols and we we found it within
clostridium perfringens that
necessarily wasn't the case so it does
seem that there is a
a a unique mechanism that's
causing this underlying antimicrobial
potential
but however what we did found with
salmonella i find with salmonella and
tarika that there was a strong
relationship between
phenol content and antimicrobial
activity for this pathogen
so we focus more on clostridium
perfringens and you can see
these dots here represent a genotype and
so these dots represent lines that have
demonstrated a lot a lot of
antimicrobial activity but had
no condensed tannins and very low total
polyphenols
this slide shows the same and just
points out several
sorghum accessions that are worth
exploring for trade introgression
here is a manhattan plot that that plots
out the g
wasps results from the quantitative
measure
of antimicrobial activity comparing that
to the genome-wide
gbs data for all these 384 sorghum lines
and and out of the top 100
snips that were associated across
clostridium and salmonella
there was only one shared genetic marker
and that was located on
chromosome 8 s83510530
and the gene annotation was a serine
threonine
uh protein phosphatase family um
the favorable allele at this at this
snip um was the c allele
and uh the
you can see it conferred it tend to
confer
a high amount or high level of
antimicrobial activity for clostridium
in particular
and you can see that that irregular
relationship or pattern with condensed
tannins and phenols so
we found certain lines that had very
little
tannins or no tannins and phenols with
high animate croco activity that
contained this
uh disfavorable allele from a broader
perspective when we looked across all
the 384 lines
you can see that this the effect of this
um
this one allele um the favorable allele
had a
uh lines had an average zone of
inhibition
uh for of 2.17 and then for the
unfavorable allele down to 0.72 so it
was a relatively large effect for this
trait
we also looked again at untargeted
metabolomics
circling back to that for for looking at
metabolites that are present in mature
sorghum grain
and to see you know what does their
relative abundance how does it correlate
with different
levels of antimicrobial activity and we
found that
there was there were metabolites that
had strong
trade-offs or correlations with the
different relative abundance of
individual mass features or metabolites
and so that provides kind of a a finer
phenotyping measure if you will to
to utilize the mass feature metabolite
that is highly correlated with your
antimicrobial trait
to look at relative abundance compare
that phenotype
to genomics information and
and run a g was on that to
um to to do a finer
point g was phenotyping strategy to
increase or try to increase the
reliability of identifying
stronger associations what you've got to
be careful of is as making sure that
this
mass feature is a is not in fact a
confounding trait effect
but it is associated with your trait and
antimicrobial activity in this case
of interest so the major takeaways from
part two
is that there was a lot of antimicrobial
activity found in sorghum it was
heritable
and there were i didn't show this but
there were no productivity trade-offs
and there weren't no trade-offs with
major macro nutrient compositional
trades and
so that was positive and and even more
positive was that there was no
significant correlation between
phenols and antimicrobial activity for
clostridium perfringens
and we identified a genetic marker that
we hope to explore in more detail and
and look at maybe developing
uh cast markers for it to implement this
trait or introduce this trait
into our elite breeding material
uh the third part and i'll be quick on
this because we are running up on
on time here and i want to leave a
little bit of time for questions
is uh this was a project funded by the
nifa orei
program looking at sorghum for
low-input organic agricultural
production sorghum is a sustainable crop
it's a non-gmo crop so it makes sense
from a from a standpoint of marketing
potential
and production potential but there has
been very little work on that
and so first we had to ask the questions
like what is the
the ideal characteristics of sorghum to
be productive under organic management
what are the traits of interest that we
need to focus on
and then within the available sorghum
germplasm that we have how competitive
are they with
with maize hybrids that were
specifically developed for
organic production
and uh this is the the breakdown of
entries into this organic trial that
encompassed a couple locations
it was 70 hybrids 72 advanced breeding
lines 43 diverse inbred lines for the
sorghum association panel
as well as a few sweet sorghum lines and
then the four commercial
maze checks when we look within sorghum
specifically what we see this
with respect to grain yield sugarcane
aphid tolerance of course had a strong
relationship
you needed hurricane aphid tolerance to
an appreciable level to have high yields
within organic production just because
you're limited with chemical inputs
another important aspect and this is
seen in wheat and other crops is
increased canopy closure canopy closure
early on in the season what's really
highly correlated
positively correlated with with terminal
yield
and so this is a trait that we really
need to focus on moving forward
here's just a couple nice slides that
that show
the level of sugar cane aphid pressure
in the field and and
these plots and in both pictures are
of the tolerance susceptible line they
were grown right next to each other the
line just separates the two plots
but you can tell that if we take this
figure on the left there's healthy
green sorghum plants that are heading
out at flowering
and on the right you can see very little
sorghum panicles being are visible
and a lot of chlorotic vegetative tissue
due to all the aphid feeding so
definitely a critical trait
fortunately we have a a major effect
gene
or locus um in rmes1
and when we looked at lines that had the
lowest surrogate aphid ratings or
pressure in the field
all but one of these lines contained the
rme s1 locus so we know it's effective
another important thing to note is in
terms of yield productivity the top
three lines possess the army s1 locus
so it was a very important uh marker
that we
that we currently screen for that we're
going to be making making sure we screen
more in depth in the future
fusarium resistance was also important
and i have harped on that you know
on in the conventional efforts of wheat
and sorghum but but it also had a major
effect on yield
and productivity in the organic study
and this was perceived to be due to
to decrease thresh ability due to the
grain mold infecting and
preventing the the grain to separate
from
the um from the chat from the glooms
one important aspect of the study is as
i mentioned that we we had a bunch of
advanced breeding lines a lot of genetic
diversity
and we had a lot of hybrids in there as
well we wanted to look at the importance
of heterosis and organic sorghum
production because
developing certified organic hybrid seed
is a major hurdle to this industry so if
we didn't need
heterosis if we can exploit pureline
cultivar development for sorghum
maybe we can alleviate that challenge
but we found that heterosis was in fact
important especially
under optimal environments the
high-yielding environment at clemson
you see a a much more significant from a
percentage heterosis basis
than our low input marginal soils
environment
at wp raw which is in the sandier part
of our state
in fact in 2020 at that location
the difference between hybrids and
inbreds was insignificant even though
there was still a little bit of yield
bump overall
for hybrids another thing to quickly
point out here is that you did have some
high yielding inbred cultivars or
advanced breeding lines that
yield very competitively among other
top hybrids organs in the trial
the the last point on this is
um we looked at again within
environments and i mentioned the low
yielding environment which is wp raw and
then the high yielding environment is
clemson
with respect to comparing against the
four commercial maze checks you can see
that
that maze really out yielded sorghum
in the the higher yielding environment
which is not a huge surprise there
but when you looked at the interactive
effect the g
by e effect you can see that these
sorghums these top ten sorghums
in in the trial overall they tend to
outperform maze
in in the low input marginal environment
and so there's plenty of opportunity
here to improve sorghum organically of
course but it does seem like
there are opportunities now to develop
commercially available sorghum lines and
hybrids for this industry
i won't go through those takeaways um
because i
again i want to leave a few times for
questions um they're pretty
self-explanatory
again just kind of going back to how our
program wants to structure itself we
want to
identify and then incorporate useful
genetics to
accelerate genetic gain but we also want
to develop those new selection schemes
to
accelerate or change the slopes over so
to speak
and accelerate genetic gain on a
year-over-year basis
and so we'll be looking at always
looking at projects within that
within that scope of work and so with
that i'll end and hopefully left time
for
for several questions um i know i had to
blow through it a little bit quickly
more quickly
than i'd like to but uh but i appreciate
everyone being uh being here on the talk
and uh happy to answer any questions
thanks rick so there are a couple
questions in the chat box do you want to
just look at the chat box and address
them
sure steve um
the the first was from ace replica
do you know if the vibe is a high
perspective what range of wavelengths
they're looking at so
um yeah so i don't know it's it's all
proprietary um
from the company we work with uh
all i can say is that it
uh it seems to be looking at more
hyperspectral
more different wavelengths to capture
more subtle variation
in in color context um
but i think there's plenty of
opportunity to improve calibrations
there as well
and we'll be looking at that
vibe qm3 grain analyzer to to look at
quality components and
and different aspects across both wheat
and sorghum too
and the next question from dr ed buckler
is
we see consistent cis effects in rna
expression
and did you profile metabolites at
multiple tissue and time points
how correlated were these profiles
across these
unfortunately we didn't we didn't have
the
opportunity to look at a time point
series or time series um
metabolite uh very variability in
abundance
obviously that's our next step we want
to do targeted metabolites
or i'm sorry targeted metabolomics
within a smaller subset of germplasm
to look at how a relative abundance
changes across the the period of
infection both pre
pre-inoculated during the inoculation
and then
several time points after inoculation
so that's our next step for sure and
then
the last question in the chat was um
from dr rebecca nelson did the
antimicrobials that were effective
against bacteria
also inhibit fungi um
really good question uh
we didn't necessarily look at that
rebecca
um we should have
but i would expect
there to be some crossover especially
when you look at salmonella and
microbial activity because
the polyphenolic pathway was highly core
or polyphenol content and tannins within
the grain was highly correlated with
that
um i'm still holding out hope that this
uh this defense mechanism or
antimicrobial mechanism
with respect to clostridium perfringens
that that is somewhat novel of a
mechanism and
and not necessarily constrained to the
traditional
polyphenolic pathway um
but we we've gotta do a lot more work on
that
uh follow-up question from rebecca is
where the
all the antimicrobials only present
after inoculation or some constitutively
express
um we we only looked at
metabolite abundance in mature grain
that was not
that was not exposed to
these foodborne pathogens and so
we wanted what our intention was is we
wanted to look at
what the natural abundance of these
metabolites are
in general um how present are they
in mature grain and then
because that's what you're going to be
feeding uh
poultry is the mature grain we wanted to
see what the concentration or abundance
of the metabolites were within that
and then try to tease that or pair that
together with
the structured antimicrobial more crude
and microbial
disdiffusion assays to to look at
extremes within the diverse sorghum
germplasm
okay any more questions or last-minute
comments
okay rick i want to thank you for your
seminar and really appreciate the
effort you're putting in there at the pd
wreck plenty to do
so thanks very much to everybody for
showing up for this seminar
oh can you say a bit more about the
organic market for
sorghum rick who's buying carolina seed
system
seed yeah it's a big question um
certainly rebecca and
i had a good talk with uh dr sorrells
this morning about
uh you know the next phase of the rei
project
is um getting the stakeholders in the
same room and figuring out
um you know how do we commercialize
these opportunities and and
make advances and um you know
that's a huge piece of the puzzle um and
we'll be working on that in the next
couple years
okay i think we're set rick so thanks
very much for your
time today appreciate it take care see
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu